شكرا للزميل نايف اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل
خير اعزائي المشاهدين واهلا بكم الى هذه
التغطيه المتواصله للتطورات الدراماتيكيه
في السودان رغم الدعوات الى الهدنه مع
دخول عيد الفطر
الجديد ان المتحدثه باسم الجيش السوداني
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اكد انه تم التصدي
لقوات الدعم السريع في محيطي مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه وفي المطار كما اكد
الجيش السوداني انه بدا مرحله جديده
لتنظيف المناطق التي توجد بها قوات الدعم
السريع حسب قوله
وفي هذه الاثناء
ظهر قائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان لاول مره منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات
ليؤكد ان السودان سيخرج من هذه الازمه
اقوى بكثير
[موسيقى]
الخراب والدمار واصوات الرصاص ما تركت
مجالا لفرحين يستحقه اهلنا في كل بلادنا
الحبيبه فاننا للجد حزينين لهذا المال لكن
يبقى الامل الدائم في اننا مع شعبنا
العظيم
سنتجاوز هذه المحنه ونخرج منها اكثر وحده
وقوه وتماسك ويزداد هتافنا قوه جيش واحد
شعب واحد فاننا على ثقه في تجاوز هذه
المحنه بالدربه والحكمه والقوه بما يحافظ
على امن ووحده البلاد وفيما يمكننا من
الانتقال الامن للحكم المدني المواطنين
الشرفاء اننا نترحم على كل شهداء بلادي
نتمنى الشفاء للجرحى وندعو الله ان يعود
علينا هذا العيد وبلادنا تنعم بالامن
والسلام تحيه لكم جند بلادي وانتم تقدمون
انفسكم فداء لهذا الوطن العزيز عاش
السودان حرا مستقلا
هذا وشهدت شوارع الخرطوم انتشار دوريات
راجله للجيش السوداني بعد ان انسحبت قوات
الدعم السريع من مواقع في العاصمه
معناتها
[موسيقى]
واعزائي المشاهدين هذه صور حصريه لقناه
العربيه من قاعده جبل سركاب شمال ام درمان
بعد سيطره الجيش السوداني على هذه القاعده
العربيه هي اول قناه تدخل الى هذه القاعده
بالطبع شمال ام درمان كان شهد قتالا عنيفا
بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع هذه المشاهد من داخل قاعده جبل
شركات في شمال ام درمان بعد ان تمكن الجيش
من السيطره على هذه القاعده كما تردنا في
هذه الصور اذا الجيش السوداني في مشاهد
خاصه وحصريه لقناه العربيه يسيطر على
قاعده جبل سركاب شمال
[موسيقى]
بالطبع شمال ام درمان حتى غرب ام درمان
كان شهد معارك عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني
والقوات الدعم السريع في محاوله من قلاء
الطرفين للسيطره على المرافق
والمواقع الاستراتيجيه في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ينضم الي رئيس
تحرير صحيفه الجريده اشرف عبد العزيز
استاذ اشرف اهلا وسهلا بك لماذا انهارت
الهدنه تماما او السؤال لماذا انهارت
الهدى جميعها ولماذا حتى الساعه لم تنجح
ولا اي هدنه في وقفه اطلاق النار برايك
باعتبار ان الكل يريد ان يحدث المزيد من
السيطره على المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
خاصه المنطقه التي تقع
في محيط القصف
الجمهور القياده العامه
الكل يريد ان يحقق هدفه السريع والخاطف
بحسم هذه المعركه لصالحه هذه المعركه هي
معركه غائبيه يعني او هي معرفه خلافات
شخصيه بين الاطراف وبالتالي يزج فيها
القوات وتحرق فيها كثير من المناطق
والمؤسسات الحيويه في سبيل ان يحقق كل
هدفه طب من يستطيع اي طرف سواء اقليمي او
دولي يستطيع فرض هدنه على الطرفين على
الاقل لاجلاء الجثث
للسماح بفتح ممرات امنه من يستطيع يعني
حتى الساعه ثلاث هدى سقطت سريعا
وفي ظل الظروف الحاليه يصعب جدا تحقيق
هدنه يمكن ان لا تفشل باعتبار ان الهدف
الرغائب هذا والرغبه هو حاضر في المشهد
ولا اتحرك الى الامام الكل يريد ان يفرز
سيطرته على هذه المنطقه المنطقه التي تقع
في القصر الجمهوري محيط القياده العامه
ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي الاكثر
اكثر مقدره للوصول لانتزاع هدنه لانها من
قبل استطعت عبر الاتصال الذي تم بين وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بالاطراف المختلفه
للوصول الى التعهد بهدنه ولكن يتم
الالتزام بها واختراقها للهدف الذي ذكرته
ايضا اسرائيل دخلت على الخط وهي لديها
علاقات دخلت على الخط ولكن في تقدير
الاكثر تاثيرا هي السعوديه والامارات ومصر
يمكن لهذه الدول الثلاثه تلعب دورا مهما
اذا تعاونت مع الاتحاد الافريقي في ذلك
استاذ اشرف ارجو ان تبقى معي اعزائي
المشاهدين سنعرض عليكم الان هذه الصور او
هذا الفيديو كما وردنا من قوات دعم السريع
تؤكد في هذا الفيديو انها سيطرت على شارع
مدني في العاصمه الخرطوم اذا قوات الدعم
السريع بقياده الجنرال احمدتي تؤكد انها
سيطرت على شارع مدني في الخرطوم برغم كل
الحديث على انها تتراجع
عنده الصباح بفعل ضربات الجيش السوداني
بقياده
المشير عبد الفتاح البرهان اذا هذه صور
لقوات الدعم السريع من شارع مدني في
الخرطوم كما تردنا والقوات الدعم السريع
تقول انها تسيطر على شارع مدني في
الخرطوم طيب استاذ اشرف اعود اليك هل
الامور وصلت الى نقطه اللعوده بين الطرفين
يعني الامر متروك للميدان وليس لاي مبادره
او هدنه
كما ذكرت ان هذه هي الحرب العبسيه هذه
الحرب يحاول فيها كل الاطراف السيطره على
هذه النقطه المحوريه ستنحصر في نهايه
الامر في الخرطوم معركه كسر عظمي ستكون في
الخرطوم في منطقه القصر الجمهوري ومحيطه
القياده العامه هذه هي المعركه الفاصله
لكن لحين ان تنجلي هذه المعركه الفاصله
ويعلن فيها المنتشره انه ينتصر ويسيطر على
هذه النزح هذه المنطقه بشكل واضح لابد ان
تكون هنالك معارك جانبيه تستمر في هذا
الاطار وبالتالي تصبح المساله يعني قد
يطول اعمدها وكل ما كل ما تاثر المواطن
صحيح في الايام الاولى كان هناك تعيدا
مطلقا للجيش باعتبار انه المؤسس الراسخه
لكن بدا ينسحب التعيين مقابل وقف هذه
الحرب لانه اذا لم تتوقف هذه الحرب فهذا
يعني ان السودان سيضيع وان الحديث سجلترا
بشكل اكبر وستكون تداعياتها وخيمه طيب بس
استاذ اشرف القول ان الخلاف هو مجرد خلاف
شخصي بين الطرفين اليس هذا تسطيحا كبيرا
لما يجري ما يجري ابعد من خلاف شخصي
نعم وابعد من خلال شخصي ولكن لكل طرف
اجنده محدده هذه الاجنده لا تخرج عن دوائر
طموح الشخصيه ايضا الكل فيهم يريد ان
يستفرد بسلطه والحكم لنفسه فبالتالي طبيعي
جدا طبيعي جدا ان يحاول مواصله الحرب
بالرغم من ان الجنود ربما قد لا تقول
لديهم رغبه لكنهم ينفعون الامر القياده في
ظل هذه الظروف
وبالتالي اذا كان مسرا الامر يحتاج الى
تفسير اكثر فمنذ البدايه كان الجيش لديه
راي واضح بانه لابد من دمج الدعم السريع
في الجيش وهذا امر طبيعي وجزء من
الموضوعيه فيما يتعلق بالعمليه السياسيه
في السودان وفي المقابل للدعم السريع ايضا
لديه راي بانه يدعم العمليه الديمقراطيه
السودان والتحول الى حكم المدني بشكل مطلق
استاذ اشرف ارجو ان تبقى معي ساعود اليك
ولكن اعزائي المشاهدين سنعرض عليكم هذه
الصور الان
للاشتباكات من حي الصحافه شرق الخرطوم اذا
اعمده الدخان الاسود الكثيف تتصاعد من هذا
الموقع الذي تعرض للقصف لندري يعني ما هو
هذا الموقع ومن اي جهه تعرض للقصف ولكن
هذه المشاهد فردنا من حي الصحافه شرق
الخرطوم حيث يشهد هذا الحي اشتباكات عنيفه
بين الطرفين وهذه يبدو ضربه قويه
يعني تتصاعد اعمده الدخان بشكل كثيف ما
يدل على ان القصف كان قويا ومركزا على هذه
النقطه او على هذا الموقع على العلم اننا
لا يمكن ان نحكم من هنا او نعرف ما هي هذا
الموقع اذا هذه المشاهد من الصحافه شرق
الخرطه استاذ اشرف
اليك يعني كان الامر انه لا خيار امام
الطرفين او بالنسبه الى الطرفين سوى الحسم
العسكري بمعنى ان المعركه بالنسبه اليه ما
هي معركه كسر عظم
من هذه العمده يعني برغم من هذا الظلام
الحالك هنالك
حديثا الذي ازلى به البرهان والذي ادلى
فيه
عمليه سياسيه في عقاب تحقيق مصري لاحقا في
هذه الازمه ويقول لهم يتحدثون عن ان هناك
اطلاق النار لكن الطرف الاخر لا يريد ذلك
صحيح الجيش
بشان انه لا يريد هدنه ولكن في المقابل هو
قال انه يريد القبض على البرهان باعتبار
انه مجرم فهذه مساله تعليه السقوف تفاوضيه
اذا وجدت ضغوط مكثفه من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وم
جلس الاتحاد الافريقي والدول الاقليميه
فبالتاكيد يمكن ان يكون هنالك تاثيرا
مطلقا يمكن ان يؤثر لغدر كبير بالانصياع
والتراجع عن هذه المساله لان مساله تعليه
للتفاوض
في هذه المعرفه ان يكسب وضعا افضل حتى
ياتي للتفاوض للتفاوض يقول انا على الارض
افضل من الثاني هذه هي النقطه الاساسيه
التي يتم فيها التفاوض هنالك مصادر اشارت
الينا وهي تقود مبادره محليه
للقياده
محاوله لوقف اطلاق النار قالت ان الازمه
اصبحت ليست ببعيده الجيش يقول انه يريد
وقت الاطلاق النار في كل الولايات
السودانيه في حين ندعم السريع تمسك بان
الوقف يقوم في الخرطوم فقط اذا هنالك بعض
الاجراءات تاخذ شكلي لكن هنالك يتحدث باسم
الجيش ويحاول ان يحرض على ضروره استمرار
الحرب
فبالتالي لابد من عدم الاستناد اليه من
الاستماع اليهم لان هذه الحرب في النهايه
المتضرر الاول منها والاخير هو الشعب
السوداني طيب استاذ اشرف ارجو ان تبقى معي
ساعود اليك اعزائي المشاهدين هذه صور
تردنا الان تظهر تحرك رتل عسكري لقوات
الدعم السريع الى شارع مدني وذلك عبر شارع
الستين في الخرطوم اذا تحركات لوحدات من
قوات الدعم السريعه هذه سيارات الدفع
الرباعي لقوات الدعم السريع في شارع مدني
عبر شارع الستين في
الخرطوم كما تردنا هذه الفيديوهات الان
كان القوات الدعم السريع قد اعلنت منذ
قليل سيطرتها على شارع مدني وسط الخرطوم
اذا هذه مشاهد لقوات الدعم السريع وبعض
الارتال
لسيارات الدفع الرباعي التابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع تجوب شارع مدني عبر شارع
الستين في
الخرطوم اشرف اعود اليك هل يمكن لاي طرف
من الاطراف المتقاتله المتحاربه الان
تحقيق نصر ماحق على الطرف الاخر ام هذا
غير مسموح ابدا يعني غير مسموح لاي طرف ان
يقوم بالحسم يعني هذه الحرب يراد لها ان
تستمر
بالتاكيد ليست بسهوله بمكان يعني وان كانت
هنالك تحركات او تكتيكات مختلفه الدعم
السريع يعتمد بشكل اساسي اصبح يحتمل
بالمواطنين في وسط الاحياء تخوف وتحسن من
ضربات الجيش والطلعات الجويه المركزه
والطيران المسيره الذي يستخدم بدقه وفي
المقابل الجيش ايضا يحاول المحاصره الدعم
السريع وخلقه وتطيق الدائره الامنيه حتى
يقدر يكمل السيطره بشكل كامل ولكن
الاخرى وهذا يتصدى هنا وهذا يحقق انتصار
اخر في تلك المنطقه الاخرى ويستطيع
الاستلامها وهكذا فبالتالي المعركه الان
هي معركه اصبح
ت حرفيه والا اذا حاله ان تنفذ زخاير قوات
الدعم السريع ولا يستطيع المواصله وتنقطع
كل حدود الامداد وهذا ما يعمل عليه الجيش
ولكن حتى الان نرى المعرفه في متكافئه بين
الاطراف هل مازال يؤمل بحل سياسي بين
الطرفين
يعني ان هل يمكن تخيل ان الطرفين سيجلسان
بعد فتره على طاوله المفاوضات ام لا يعني
هذا يعني من سابع المستحيلات يعني وصلت
الامور الى نقطه اللاعوده بين الطرفين
هذا الامر وارد بالرغم من تعليه السقوف
لانه كما ذكرت ان المساله الكل يريد ان
يثبت انه هو الاقوى ومن بعد ذلك يمكن ان
يجلس الى طاوله المفاوضات وهو على الارض
لديه وضع افضل في تقدير هذا هو سبب
باستمرار الحرب حتى وان كانت هنالك خيارات
عالميه يمكن ان يكون هنالك موافقه لان
الانتصار الحازم ليس سهلا يعني يمكن ان
يسبب في كثير من الضحايا ووقوع كثير منهم
خاصه وان ذلك في انهيار النظام الصحي وبدا
يظهر في الند في المواد الاستهلاكيه وفي
النزوح المستمر وفي الاشياء التي بدات
تقديرها حيضا من خطاب البرهان الذي قال ان
الشعب السوداني حزين وتشرد الاطفال وتشرد
الكبار
وتم غسل الكثير من السودانيين في حرب
عبسيه ليس لديها يعني اي معنى او او ما
اشار اليه في هذا الصدق يعني بمعنى انه
يعبر بحكمه وبالرغم من تاكي بان الامور
ستحسم لكن غايه ستحسن بالحكمه والتربه
والقوه هذه المستندات الثلاث الحكمه تعني
انه يمكن الوصول الى حلول عبر هذه الحكمه
والدرفه تعني انه يمكن تدابير ان توقف هذا
الاشكال والقوه اي تستمر القوه الى تحقيق
النصر الحاسب اذا هو ترك ثلاث خيارات في
تقديري بالرغم من انه تحدث بان الحسم هو
الاساس طيب ابقى معي استاذ اشرف سعودي
اليك اعزائي المشاهدين ايضا نتابع اولا
باول هذه الصور تردنا
المشاهد من المحاله التجاريه في الخرطوم
بالطبع المدنيون في السودان هم اول من
يدفع هذه ضريبه هذه الحرب مشاهد لعمليات
سلب ونهب للمحال التجاريه في الخرطوم
بطبيعه الحال يعني في ظروف الحرب قد يبدو
كل شيء مباح في بعض
المناطق والاقاليم وانها لان الامور حرب
لا يوجد واسع او رقيب عندما تنهار مؤسسات
الدوله
وتحترم الاطراف بالطبع يدفع المدنيون
الثمن باهظا اذا مشاهد
لعمليات نهب وسالب في الخرطوم
قال عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه الاطباء
في السودان العربيه ان 11 طبيبا قتلوا
خلال المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى التعرض عدد من
المستشفيات الى القصف ما تسبب بتوقف عمل
بعض المستشفيات
الطبيه
هما ثمانيه من الكوادر الطبيه وثلاثه من
طلاب كليات الطيب
تعدت اسباب قتلهم اما بالرصاص المباشر او
سقوط دانات داخل منازلهم نعم احد عشر في
مجموعهم 14 مستشفى تعرضها للقصف المباشر
او الغير مباشر في النهايه هي تعرضت لدمار
جزء او دمار كامل ايضا هنالك عدد من
الكوادر الطبيه تعرضت للعنف وبعض منهم
مصاب
للعنف الذي واجهوه في الشوارع اثناء
قيامهم باداء واجبهم تجاه
المستشفيات القادمه والمرضاهم
هذا وثقت كاميرا العربيه من داخل مدينه
مروي بالولايه الشماليه وفق التفاصيل اول
ايام عيد الفطر المبارك بعد اشتباكات
ومعارك شهدها مطار مروي والقاعده الجويه
الملحقه بالمطار
كل عام وانتم بخير
نحن الان داخل الفرقه التاسعه عشر مشاه في
مدينه مروي بالولايه الشماليه هذه ملامح
العيد في اول يوم من ايام عيد الفطر
المبارك
الله اكبر الله
اكبر ومن ارض مروع طيب الصامته الطاهره
لنرسل الرساله
للشعب السوداني بنقول لهم نحن صامدين
والعدوى
امن ان شاء الله
واكد تماما بان الولايه خاليه تماما من اي
وجود للفلول عدد من الاسر في الولايات
الشماليه وتحديدا في مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه فقدت ابنائها خلال الاشتباكات
العنيفه المسلحه التي دارت خلال العمليات
العسكريه داخل المطار وداخل القاعده
العسكريه سنقترب اكثر لنتعرف على شكل
العيد في الاسر التي فقدت بعضا من ابنائها
خلال هذه الحرب
ولدي
الشهيد احمد محمد احمد عوض الله
الذي استشهد بمطار المرعب القاعده الجويه
هو عند الله شهيدا ان شاء الله
والحمد لله رب العالمين حصل علينا الشهداء
كتير ان احنا فقدناهم في في الاحداث اللي
كان والله ما زي زمان يعني
لطالما ترسخت الطمانينه والامن في هذه
المنطقه كرسوق اشجار النخيل في ارض الشمال
ياتي العيد ودعوات الناس هنا اي عم الامن
والاستقرار والسلام ارجى السودان نزار
البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث محليه
مروي الولايه الشماليه
هذا واظهرت مقاطع فيديو متداوله انتشار
الجيش السوداني في شوارع العاصمه الخرطوم
وسط ترحيب من قبل الاهالي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا وانتشر مقطع فيديو يظهر سيارات دفع
رباعي مدمره تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع بعد
ما قصفتها القوات الجويه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
بالطبع هذه مشاهد تردنا الان اعزائي
المشاهدين
لقوات الدعم السريع من داخل مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون السودانيه اذا الهيئه العامه
كما تشاهدون للاذاعه والتلفزيون هذا
المبنى
تسيطر عليه قوات الدعم السريع لكن مبنى
البث يعني يسيطر عليه الجيش السوداني حيث
تبث البيانات
للجيش السوداني اذا يعني المعركه سجال حتى
في الخرطوم يعني من مبنى الى مبنى مبنى
يسيطر عليه الجيش مبنى تسيطر عليها قوات
الدعم السريع اذا هذا هذه المشاهد لقوات
الدعم السريع من مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
ولكن اعيده واكرر ان المبنى البث يتحكم به
الجيش السوداني بقياده الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان
هذا وقالت مجموعه الازمات الدوليه في بيان
لها ان الاشتباكات الحاليه في السودان قد
تتطور الى حرب اهليه في حال لم يتوقف
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع كما دعت المنظمه البلدان المجاور
للسودان وكل من لديه علاقه وثيقه مع
البرهان واحمدتي بان يتم التواصل معهما
لايجاد حل مناسب ووقف الاشتباكات بين
القوتين
من القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم الي
البحث في العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور احمد
سيد احمد دكتور احمد اهلا وسهلا بك كيف
تراقب مصر تطورات الوضع السوداني الخطير
جدا في اليوم الساعه السادس لهذه
المواجهات ولهذا الاقتتال العنيف
تحياتي لك ولكل المشاهدينك الكرام في
الواقع ان مصر منذ اللحظه الاولى لاندلاع
هذه المواجهات وهي تراقب عن كثب وتتحرك
على مستويات عديده
ومستويات سياسيه فيما يتعلق به العام على
الوقف اطلاق النار التهدئه محاوله الاتصال
به او الاتصال بالاطراف المباشره للازمه
من اجل دفعهم الى الهدنه والتغليف لغه
العقل ايضا المسار الثاني التنسيق مع
القوى الاقليميه الفاعله في الاقليم
ولديها ايضا مؤثره السعوديه الامارات من
اجل ايضا دفع بدور عربي في تحقيق التهدئه
وتحقيق استقرار السودان وتغليف لغه العقل
والحكمه وايضا المسار الثالث وهو ايضا
مسار اقليمي خاص بالجانب الافريقي مثل مع
جنوب السودان او من خلال الاتحاد الافريقي
لدفع الاطراف ايضا الى التهدئه والى تغليب
لغه العقد ثم المسار الرابع ايضا هو مسار
دولي في متعلق سواء الامم المتحده او
امريكا او القوى ايضا المؤثره في السودان
مصر تراقب لان مصر هي اكثر دوله بالطبع هي
متاثره بشكل مباشر او التطورات او مسار
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان لان اي مسار
يكون سيكون سلبي سمع يتعلق بتعقيد الازمه
او تراجع او ضعف او انهيار الدوله
السودانيه او مؤسساتها لا قدر الله او
الدخول في حرب اهليه وكل هذه السنهرهات
سيكون لها انعكاس مباشر حقيقه على مصر
فيما يتعلق بالجانب الامني فيما يتعلق
بالجانب حتى الانسان مع تفاقم الازمه
الانسانيه وبالطبع هناك تخوف مخاوف من
تكرار او 60 ساخ النموذج الليبي الان في
السودان في ظل تمدرس في ظل حرب المقرات في
ظل الحرب العالميه كل طرف يعلن الانتصار
وعلى الطرف الاخر لكن بعد سبعه ايام من
المعارك ما زالت
الكلمه الان هي العليا هي لغه السلاح هي
لغه الرصاص الجيش بيعتبر ان امر الحاسم
العسكري امر
ايضا القوات الدفع السريعه تقوم بالقر
والفار بعض المقرات ثم تنشر لكن في كلا
الاحوال مع مرور الوقت وعدم حل الازمه هذا
بيفاقب من ابعاد الازمه القضيه لم تعد فقط
مجرد هدنه ولكن هناك ابعاد اعمق من هذا
الامر طيب دكتور احمد سعود اليك ارجو ان
تتفضل بالبقاء معي انضم اليه الان عبر
الهاتف مدير الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه
والعون الانسانيه الصادق محمد احمد السيد
احمد اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه
المتواصله من قناه العربيه اولا اي تقييم
للاوضاع الانسانيه وهل لديكم اي داله على
ما يجري في المدن السودانيه تحديدا في
الخرطوم ولو تعطينا فكره عن الوضع
الاستشفائي الطبي
المياه الكهرباء تفضل
طبعا
حرج جدا فيما يتعلق بامدادات الغذاء وايضا
فيما يتعلق بالوضع الانساني في المستشفيات
خصوصا لان الان اصبح هناك عزيمه انسانيه
كبيره اضيفت الى نقص الغذاء ونقص المواد
التموينيه وظيفه اليها اخلاء الجرحى من
الشوارع هناك كارثه انسانيه يعني
تحيط يعني بالوضع بصوره عامه والنقشه ان
يتم ايضا انتشار الامراض من جراء وجود بعض
الجثث الكثير من الجثث الان في الشوارع
ولم يتم اخلاقها وستتحلل بمرور الايام
وجود ممرات امنه امر مهم جدا ولكن هناك
مخاوف من الجيش الجيش
صرح انه ليس لديه مانع من ان تكون هناك
امدادات انسانيه ولكن على الارض هناك
انتشار كبير
لقوات الدعم السريع في مختلف الشوارع وهذا
يعيق ايضا حركه الاطقم الانسانيه اذا ما
تم فتح هذه الممرات هناك ايضا مخاوف من ان
تقوم هذه
القوات التي على في الشوارع قوات الدعم
السريع
بالسطو على الامدادات الانسانيه لانه
راينا في الايام السابقه انهم اقاموا بكسر
المحلات التجاريه
والاعتداء على المواطنين في منازلهم هناك
مخالف كبيره من ان يتم
ايضا الاحتلال الكبير على المنظمات
الدوليه وعلى اطقم المنظمات الدوليه قتل
ثلاثه اشخاص من برنامج الغذاء العالمي قبل
ايام هو مما ادى الى تعليق عمل البرنامج
الغذائي العالمي وبالتالي ايضا جميع
منظمات الامم المتحده تتخوف من
الوضع غير امن على الارض حتى تقوم بامداد
المواطنين بالمواد الغذائيه وكذلك
بالمستشفيات بما تحتاجه هذه المستشفيات من
امصال ومن ادويه وغيره الوضع يحتاج الى
اكثر من من تنسيق يحتاج الى وقفه عاجله من
الفاعلين الدولي ين لحس الاطراف المتنازعه
على ان تجنيح الى فتح ممرات امنه وضمان
عدم تعرض اطقم القوات
الدوليه التي تعمل على امداد المواطنين
بهذه المواد استاذ احمد هل لديكم اي اتصال
مع طرفي النزاع من اجل ارسال اي مساعدات
دوليه عاجله ام لا يوجد اي اتصال
التواصل مع الحكومه السودانيه ممثله في
القوات المسلحه قائم هي هي التي لها
الكلمه العليا الان
نحن يعني بان هناك مع قوات الدعم السريعه
لديكم اي تواصل ام التواصل مقطوع تماما
ليس لها اداره مركزيه حتى يتم التعامل
معها حاليا هناك فقدان للسيطره على هذه
القوات ليس هناك كلمه لقياده القوات الدعم
السريعه على افرادها المنتشرين هم يعملون
بصوره فرديه كل مجموعه
مركزيه او اداره مركزيه او منطقه سيطره
يمكن ان يتم الاتصال مع الدعم السريع
الدعم السريع تقريبا هو فاقد للموصله
حاليا هذا هو التقييم
الحالي يعني استاذ احمد طيب اذا في حال
ارادت اي وكاله دوليه الان ارسال مساعدات
عاجله غذائيه او طبيه الى السودان الى
الخرطوم هل هذا متاح يعني هل تستطيع هل
هنالك ضمانات بان تصل هذه المساعدات ام لا
لا يمكن باي شكل من الاشكال تحت هذه
الظروف ارسال اي مساعده الى السودان
هذا ما نتحدث عنه الان هذا ما نطلب نطالب
به ان يكون هناك ضمان لسلامه هذه الاطقم
الانسانيه التي ستعمل على الارض الجيش وعد
بان خلال اليومين القادمين ان يكون هناك
اتصال
الدوليه بفتح
المناطق لها بتامين ايضا المنطقه كل كامله
خصوصا العاصمه السودانيه وننتظر منهم
تاكيد ذلك حتى يتم امداد المواطنين
والمستشفيات ما تحتاجه من مواد انسانيه
استاذ احمد اريد فقط يعني انت وان كنت
تتحدث الينا من لندن ولكن لك داله على
الوضع في السودان اكثر منا هنا ولا تصلك
المعلومات من مصادر بالنسبه الى موضوع
النزوح يعني لاحظنا نزوح داخلي ونزوح
خارجي يعني نزوح داخلي من مناطق وولايات
في السودان الى ولايات اخرى ونضوح خارجي
باتجاه تشاد يعني عشرات الالاف قيل من
السودانيين نزحوا باتجاه تشاد هل لديكم اي
معطيات وافيه وارقام عن حركه النزوح نتيجه
هذه الحرب
اعتقد ان الرقم عشرات الالاف من المواطنين
الذي نجحوا الى تشاد رقم مبالغ فيه هي
اعداد محدوده حسب معلوماتنا ان هناك اعاده
350 من
السودانيين فروا الى تشاد وهم في مناطق في
مناطق الحدوديه اصلا ولكن النزوح داخل
السودان
نعلهم
اهل في منطقه الجزيره او مناطق الامن التي
يستطيع الوصول اليها خرجوا ولكن للاسف حتى
بعض هذا المواطنين تعرضوا الى
الاعتداء من قبل قوات الدعم السريع في
اثناء خروجهم خصوصا في شارع
الخرطوم مدني عند خروجهم تحصلنا على
افادات وادله على تعرض عدد من المواطنين
في السيارات
تتمركز عند مخارج العاصمه في منطقه سوبا
والباقير وقاموا بالاعتداء على المواطنين
كذلك وتفتيشهم هناك سياراتهم هناك حاله
نعتقد ان الجيش السوداني حريص على ان يتم
باسرع وقت ممكن عمل اعاده عمل المنظمات
الاغاثه العالميه في السودان وذلك لتامين
وصول الغذاء لهم واستاذ النقص الحاصل في
المواد التموينيه وكذلك الادويه هذا اهم
شيء الان الذي يشغل بال المنظمات الدوليه
هو العمل على امداد المستشفيات انه هناك
عدد كبير من الجرحى والقتله ويحتاج الامر
الى تحرك عاجل جدا في هذا الاتجاه استاذ
احمد فقط ايضا لو تمدنا ببعض المعلومات هل
لديكم اي ارقام لعدد المستشفيات التي ما
زالت تعمل يعني يقال انه 90 الى 95% من
مستشفيات الخرطوم خرجت عن الخدمه هل هذا
الرقم مبالغ فيه ام لا يعني هنالك وجه من
الحقيقه يعني نتيجه الاوضاع الدراماتيكيه
التي تمر على العاصمه
نعم صحيح الرقم قد يكون مقارب الى هذا هذه
النسبه كبير من المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه
وذلك بسبب النقص اولا وبسبب كذلك اعتداء
قوات الدعم السريع على الاطم الطبيه هناك
عدد كبير مستشفيات جنوب الخرطوم قامت قوات
الدعم السريع باخلاء الجرحى والقتل الى
هذه المستشفيات وبعد وصول للقوات المسلحه
الى منطقه هذه المستشفيات طعمه بترك الجثث
واخذ الكثير من المواد الطبيه اصلا
المتبقيه في هذه المستشفيات مراجعه وكذلك
اخذوا معهم بعض الاطعمه الطبيه لعلاج
جرحهم ميدانيا مما ادى الى خلو المستشفيات
وايضا
الخدمه وهذه هي الكارثه الحقيقيه الان عدم
صفات التي تعمل على اصابع الايدي
منطقه السلاح المهندسين سلاح طبي في
الاندرمان التي تعمل حاليا وهي تقوم
باخلاء الجرح القوات المسلحه
وعلاجهم
بعض المستشفيات في الاطراف جميع خرجت عن
الخدمه جنوب الخرطوم الخرطوم البحرين
وكذلك في ام درمان بعض المستشفيات فقط
التي في في المنطقه التي تكاد تكون
السيطره فيها للقوات المسلحه وعدم وجود
افراد من الدعم الشريعي ينتشرون في
شوارعها هي التي حاليا استاذ احمد مع
العلم انه يعني من المفترض ان يكون ان
يشكل السودان سله غذائيه لكل القاره
الافريقيه والى غيرها من الدول ولكن كما
نعرف الاوضاع التي يمر بها السودان لا
يحسد عليها ابدا
قرات منذ يومين تقرير لبعض الباحثين في
اليو ان دي بي يقولون انه اذا استمرت
الحرب لاكثر من شهر فان بعض الولايات
ستضربها المجاعات هل هذا الكلام مبالغ فيه
ام لا في وجه من الحقيقه
اعتقد ان الازمه حاليا تتركز في العاصمه
الولايات كما تعلم لها بعض لحسن الحظ بها
بخصوص المناطق الزراعيه
التقاء تكون مكتفيه يعني ذاتيا بالمواد
الغذائيه وما الى ذلك خصوص المناطق
الجزيره في شمال السودان ولكن في منطقه
العاصمه لانه الامداد المواد الغذائيه
ياتي معظمه من الولايات والان امكانيه
تحرك التجار ونقل المواد الغذائيه الى
العاصمه الخرطوميه كان يكون متوقف تماما
بسبب العمليات العسكريه حاليا الجاريه
الحمل عندهم الاستقرار السياسي هي السبب
الرئيسي والمحنه الرئيسيه لشعب السوداني
في حاله تم استقرار سياسي اعتقد ان
السودان سيكون هناك ازمه
الصادق محمد احمد مدير وكاله التنميه
والعون الانسانيه في الوكاله الدوليه
للتنميه من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه اعود الى من قطع من حديث مع
البحث في العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور احمد
سيد احمد تحدث الي من القاهره دكتور احمد
كنت قد سالتك هل دخل السودان نقطه العوده
يعني في معركه كسر عظم لا كلام غير صوت
المدفع والرصاص وكل حديث عن هدنه او وقف
اطلاق النار هذا كلام لا اساس له من الصحه
بالفعل يعني عندما نتكلم عن هدنه يعني
الهدنه لديها مقومات حتى غير متوفره في كل
هدن السودان يعني اولا التكافؤ بين الطرفي
الازمه تتكلم عن قوات نظاميه لديها قياده
مركزيه تستطيع السيطره على كل القوات
المنتشره والجهه اتصالات
هو الجيش السوداني في مقابل قوات الدعم
السريع التي هي افراد تتحرك على العربيات
دفع رباعيه تتحدث بكل مجموعه في كل شارع
بها قائد يتحرك به مفرده بقراراته
وبالتالي من الصعب السيطره او ان تكون
هناك قياده مركزيه غير موجوده هذه القياده
وهذا حقيقه ما يفشل هذه الهدن بين الامرين
هذا من ناحيه من الناحيه الاخرى ايضا
النظر بكل الطرف الى الاخر يعني في حديث
البرهان وحميد تيم خلال الايام الماضيه كل
منهما يرى ان الحل هو في ذهاب الاخر وليس
في التفاوض والحوار مع الاخر والجيش
السوداني يعتبر ان اي حديث عن هدنه هو
سيعطي الشرعيه والفرصه
السريع للبقاء الوضع كما هو عليه وفرض
واقع جديد وايضا في المقابل الدعم السريع
يحاول الحصول على اكبر مكتسبات لفرض منطق
وواقع جديد ولهذا يفسر لماذا الاصرار على
السيطره على الثلاث مقرات الحيويه القص
القاده العامه القصر الجمهوري مطار
الخرطوم باعتبار انها تمثل السياده تمثل
الرمز ومن يسيطر عليها سيكون له الكلمه
العليا في ايه مفاوضات او اي اذا تم الدفع
بالجانبين الى هذا الامر الامر الثالث
ايضا وهو ان الهدنه لا يعني لا تتم في
سياق بمعنى الهدنه هل مطلوب فقط هو وقف
اطلاق النار والتقاط الانفاس هنا قد تكون
عامل سلبي لان كل طرف سيحشد ايضا بزمن
القوات لكن عندما توضع الهدنه في سياق
مرتبط بالتفاهمات السياسيه يعني ما هو هل
سنعود الى الوضع ما قبل 15 ابريل هذا ايضا
وضع مستحيل لان حاله العوده والطلاق
البائن بين الجانبين قد حدث ايضا الواقع
ان يتم الحوار والتفاوض هما هذا ايضا من
الصعب ثم السيناريو ان ينتصر طرف ويسحق
الطرف الاخر هو ايضا صعب رغم ان الجيش
السوداني كل المؤشرات مع استمرار الوقت
الميزان القوه يميل لصالحه هو يسيطر بحكم
التماسك بحكم التموين بحكم الامدادات بحكم
عوامل كثيره على عكس ربما الدعم السريع
الذي يفقد السيطره والمزيل القوه التلاته
لصالحه وبالتالي لكن السؤال هو هل سيكون
الهدنه ان يكون في سياق ما هو وضع الدعم
السريع ما هو هذا الموقف ما هو التعامل مع
100 الف من قوات الدعم ايضا هناك ابعاد
دوليه يعني هناك ابعاد محركه من وراء
الستار لهذا الامر يعني الاقرار الدعم او
قرار بعض القرارات ليست هي مرتبطه بقرارات
اخرى من وراء الستار هناك قوه داخليه هناك
في السودان تدعم او تمثل حاضنه كما نعرف
ربما حليه والتغيير الدعم هناك قوه خارجيه
يعني القرار الهدنه هو مرتبط بابعاد
متشابكه ومعقده هذا يفسر لنا لماذا الهدنه
يتم اتفاق عليه ثم تنهار بعد ساعات قليله
بمعنى هناك محاوله واصرار او هناك توجه
لاستمرار هذا الوضع واستمرار هذه الحرب
وبالتالي كل طرف يحاول تحقيق مكاسب من
خلال هذه الهدى لكن
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من القاهره البحث في
العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور احمد سيد احمد
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
وكما اردنا اعزائي المشاهدين في سياق هذه
التغطيه منذ قليل هذه الصور لكاميرا
العربيه صور حصريه
العربيه كانت اول وسيله اعلاميه تتمكن من
تصوير قاعده الدعم السريع في منطقه جبل
سركاب شمال ام درمان قوات الجيش السوداني
سيطرت تماما على هذه القاعده نشاهد مزيد
من المشاهد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قاعده كرري العسكريه
معسكر الدعم السريع سابقا والان نسيطر
عليه المسلحه بفضل من الله ونصرا مؤزر
وتمت السيطره على على القاعده يوم الاحد
اما الجيوب المتبقيه والقوات الان تلاحق
فيها للسيطره وانهاء الموقف
هذا واكد دبلوماسيون اوروبي للعربيه انه
يتم العمل مع الهيئات الدوليه ودول الخليج
من اجل تحقيق وقف لاطلاق النار وتثبيت
الهدنه في السودان
واضافت دبلوماسيه الاوروبيه ان السودان
دوله محوريه في افريقيا وان تاثيرات
النزاع قد تطالوا المنطقه من غرب افريقيا
وحتى القرن الافريقي
قررت كل من كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان ارسال
طائرات الى السودان بقصد اجلاء المواطنين
الموجودين هناك وقالت وكاله انباء كوريا
الجنوبيه ان جميع مواطنيها في السودان
والبالغ عددهم 25 شخصا ما زالوا بخير وسط
انباء باحتماليه تفاقم الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع الا ان
الوكاله الكوريه لم توضح في اي مطار
سوداني ستهبط طائره الاجلاء
هذا وقال سلفاكير رئيس جنوب السودان ان
بلاده فوجئت بالاشتباكات العسكريه التي
شهدتها الخرطوم واكد سيلفاكير انه جاهز
للذهاب الى الخرطوم اذا ما قدمت السلطات
السياسيه ضمانات بان مطار الخرطوم لا
تهدده اي مشاكل امنيه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
لانه ذاته دخلنا فيه نتكلم الطرفين
يعني يقبل وسلام وما يخرج بدم
ما بينفع
منتظرين من الخرطوم يقول لنا يا جماعه
ما في صوره تلقى في الخرطوم
واي طائره ممكن تنزل في المطاعر بتاع
الخرطوم
انا
هذا طلب عدد من السودانيين المقيمين في
جوبا طالب قائد الجيش السوداني وقائد
الدعم السريع بوقف القتال في السودان بشكل
فوري حقنا للدماء يطلب من يحتكم الى
القتيل هو من السودان
قاتل هو من السودان فبتالي يكون خساره
للجانبين انا اتمنى انه الامن
اقول للاخوان يا جماعه
ما شاء الله متعلمين والناس ترجع تتفق
والناس تعيش في الامن ارجعوا الى صوت
العقل صوت الحكمه المسلم على المسلم حرام
نحن ما محتاجين مشاكل اقعدوا في الواطه
وحلوا مشاكلهم الكرسي اصلا ما مهم نحن
مهمتنا نمشي قدام ونلحق برقبه الامم دي
الحاجه المطلوبه
الى ذلك قالت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه انها
على تواصل مستمر مع السلطات السودانيه
لتسهيل عوده مواطنيها عبر المعابر البريه
في السودان من دون عوائق واضافت الخارجيه
المصريه في بيان النشيرته على الفيسبوك
انها توصل من خلال بعثاتها في السودان
بدله كافه الجهود والقيامه بالاتصالات
اللازمه لمتابعه اوضاع الجاليه المصريه في
البلاد خلال هذه الازمه والطاعات السريع
معها تبعا للمستجدات
الى القاهره الان تنضم الي لمزيد من
المتابعه مديره مكتب العربيه رندا ابو
العزم رنده اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه اخر
التصريحات والمواقف من القاهره حول تطورات
المشهد السوداني قبل ان اسالك رنده عن اي
اجلاء محتمل للرعايه المصريه في السودان
انا تابعت
المسائل كبيره جدا على مستويين على
المستوى الدبلوماسي من خلال اتصالات
ونداءات ومبادرات وجهها الرئيس السيسي
وكان اخرها مع رئيس جنوب السودان لوقف
اطلاق النيران لان عمليه وقف اطلاق
النيران بيترتب عليها كل ما هو ما يحدث
ولكن من الواضح ان هناك خلق لهذه الهدن
يوما بعد
يومكنت في هدنه واحده فقط في
استرجاع جنود كانوا محتاجين هناك وما زال
الجزء الاخر في السفاره المصريه
بالخرطوم
ايضا كان هناك تواصل كبير جدا عبر وزاره
الخارجيه المصريه مع عدد من
وزراء الخارجيه الاوروبيين كان اخرها
بالامس مع وزير خارجيه هولندا وزير خارجيه
الهند الذين طالبوا مصر التنسيق لسهوله
الخروج ده رعايه تلك الدول من خلال وسطات
مصريه او حتى عن طريق الحدود المصريه اذا
المساعي المصريه بتبذل منذ اليوم الاول
كان هناك ايضا متابعه من وزيره الهجره
المصريه الاوضاع الطلاب الموجودين في
السودان
بحسب ما علمنا انه لا يوجد عدد معروف
لهؤلاء الطلاب ما بين ثلاثه الاف وما
الذين سجلوا لكن قيل انهم 5000 فقط في
الخرطوم بين جاليه المصريه بتبلغ 10,000
في الخرطوم ولكن الجاليه المصريه بحسب ما
نعلم هي اكبر بكثير من هذا من هذا العدد
ما ما يتم الان وما تقوم به مصر وايضا
المؤسسات الدوليه الجامعه العربيه الامم
المتحده وهو محاوله
اطلاق النيران هذا هو المحك الرئيسي لاي
تبعات فيما بعد
راندا راندا ولكن هل هنالك يعني كوريا
الجنوبيه اليابان وعدد من الدول بدات بوضع
خطط لاجلاء راعيها بالطبع رعايا هذه الدول
اقل بكثير من الرعايه المصريين الموجودين
في السودان يعني حتى انت ما فيش رقم محدد
يعني ولكن حتى في الخرطوم قلت الان يعني
اكثر من 10,000
مصري موجود في الخرطوم والارقام بالطبع
اكثر بكثير اذا ما اشتملت على باقي
الولايات والمدن السودانيه هل بدات مصر
تفكر بوضع خطط لاجلاء رعاياها في حال
استمرت الحرب وعنفت في المرحله المقبله ام
حتى الساعه وفق مع المعلومات المتوفره
لديك لا وجود لتفكير بهذا الشكل يعني لا
وجود لخطط اجلاء للرعايه المصريين من
السودان
هناك خطط توضع منذ اليوم الاول ولكن في ظل
التبادل اطلاقي نيران وعدم سيطره قوات
الدفع السريعه على بعض قواتها في بعض
المناطق بيصعب تحرك هؤلاء المصريات حتى
تحدثنا الى بعض من هم هناك في الخرطوم
ذكروا ان هناك صعوبه كبيره جدا في الوصول
من الخرطوم الى وادي حلفا تبعد نحو 900
كيلومتر
البساطه التي كانت او الحافلات التي كانت
تقلهم هناك كان سعر التذكره 30 دولار الان
300 دولار عبر بعض الشركات الخاصه نعم
حتى يعني اطلاق النيران هذه عمليه بتحفها
مخاطر كبيره جدا لكي يصل اي طالب مصري من
الخرطوم الى وادي حلفا اما عن القنصليات
المصريه المتواجده في وادي حلفا فهي
بتساهل الان اذا كان هناك مسلم متواجدون
بالفعل هناك سيتم عبورهم عبر المنفذ ولكن
يعني بحسب المصادر عمليه تسهيل العبور
المواطنين عبر المنافذ تعلم ان هناك منفذ
بري هو قص الاشكير هو بيبعد نحو ساعتين
ونصف الى من من السودان الى مدينه ابو
سمبل وخمسه ونصف الى مدينه الى محافظه
اسوان هناك غرفه عمليات بحسب ما علمنا من
مصادرنا طالب من كافه الاجهزه الامنيه
والجهات المعنيه لتامين نقل المصريين عبر
هذا المنفذ البري لكن بيعتمد على اصولهم
او نجاحهم في الوصول الى هذا المنهج حتى
هذه اللحظه لا توجد ممرات امنه ولم يتم
التوصل يعني في حاله الوصول لوقت اطلاق
هناك سهوله عدد كبير من الطلاب المصريين
بيطالبوا بالفعل بالخروج
وباللعبور الى الى مصر ولكن ما علمناه
ايضا وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا ان العبور سيكون
في اتجاه واحد فقط وليس لن يكون من من مصر
الى السودان ولكن سيكون من السودان الى
مصر للطلاب او للمصريين الذين يريدون
المغادره سؤال اخير هل لدى الخارجيه
المصريه اتصالات مع طرفي النزاع مع طرفي
القتال املا الاتصالات مقتصره مع الحكومه
الاطراف الحكوميه ومع الجيش بقياده الفريق
عبد الفتاح البرهان
الجنود المصريين كان هناك اتصالات مباشره
او غير مباشره وهذا صدر في بيانات رسميه
طيب من القاهره مديره مكتب العربيه رندا
ابو العزم شكرا جزيلا لك رنده على كل هذه
المتابعه
اعزائي المشاهدين غصوا عيد الفطر في
السودان باصوات اطلاق النار تزامنا مع
تلبيات الصلاه منذ ساعات الفجر الاولى وما
بين عام واخر يختلف المشهد من مساجد مقتظه
الى اعداد شحيحه خوفا من القصف المتبادل
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
تكبيرات تختلط بزيز الرصاص عيد السودان
يبكي اهله باعداد شحيحه في المصليات
يخرجون من المساجد فرادى لا مصلين
يرتادونها كما عهد عيد الفطر فرحته
بازدحامهم لكن بعضهم لم يابه كثيرا بتلك
المعارك فخرجوا رغما عن الصراع ولبوا نداء
السعاده بمعايده مغلفه باطلاق النيران
وكل عام
عيد لم تكتمل اركانه في السودان كتب على
اهله البقاء في المنازل او الخروج لاقتناص
صلاه بصحبه الاقارب او الاصدقاء والعوده
قبل ان تخطئهم باروده تلك الاشتباكات لا
حول ولا قوه
فرحه مسلوبه الا من امنيه اتحد عليها
السودانيون يرجون فيها ان ينعم بلدهم
بالامن والاستقرار
ان نرجع السودان الاصلي
والبركه والخير يعني وتتوقف الحرب والناس
وصلوا يعني لاتفاق والناس تعيش بامني
وسلام
ان شاء الله الوضع يتحسن ان شاء الله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر هكذا كان السودان على الاقل منذ
سنه لكنه يعيش مشاهد غير مالوفه يغص بها
البلد الذي اعتاد التهافت الى شوارع تفوح
فيها رائحه حلوى العيد ومن ذاك العام الى
هذا العام تكتب حرب الجنرالات ان تبقي
ذكريات العيد الماضي حاضره بطقوسها في
مخيلتهم لا وقعهم المرير اسراء الصغير
العربيه
هذا ونشر الجيش السوداني مقطع فيديو يظهر
عضو مجلس السياده الفريق اول ياسر عطا وهو
يتفقد القوات التي نشرها الجيش اليوم في
الخرطوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الان الى جوله على ابرز الاخبار العالميه
غير الشان السوداني فقد قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان لها ان
الاجراءات والخطابات الاخيره من اوكرانيا
تظهر ان روسيا بحاجه الى مواصله العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا مؤكده ان
العمليه ستستمر حتى تكتمل اهدافها المعلنه
والمتمثله في نزع السلاح والقضاء على
التهديدات للامن القومي الروسي
قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسي
يانسوس ان مستقبل اوكرانيا في انضمامها
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي مؤكدا ان حلفاء
النيتو قد اجمعوا على ان تصبح اوكرانيا
عضوا في هذا الحلف
قلت في كييف بالامس ان مستقبل اوكرانيا
يكمن في الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
وكل حلفاء النيتو قد اجمعوا على ان تصبح
اوكرانيا عضوا في النيتو لكن يجب ان نركز
الان على كيفيه ضمان انتصار اوكرانيا في
الحرب ضد روسيا
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي خلال اجتماع
حلفاء اوكرانيا في المانيا لتنسيق
المساعدات العسكريه لكيف قال ان باشنطون
قدمت 36 حزمه مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا
بلغت قيمتها اكثر من خمسه وثلاثين مليار
دولار
بدايه الاسبوع اعلنت الولايات المتحده عن
الحزمه 36 من المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا التي تبلغ قيمتها
325 مليون دولار اذا نحن قدمنا مساعده
عسكريه لاوكرانيا حتى الان بقيمه تصل الى
اكثر من 35 مليار دولار منذ بدء العدوان
الروسي الحزمه الاخيره تضمنت صواريخ هاي
مارس ومدافع 155
مستمرون بتقديم المساعدات لاوكرانيا على
المدى الطويل
اكد وزير الخارجيه الصينيه ان بلاده تلتزم
بالمبادئ العادله للدعوه الى الوساطه
والحوار للحد من التوترات في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
بما اننا نواجه ازمه طويله الامد في
اوكرانيا فان الصين لا تزيد النار اشتعالا
وتستغل الوضع ولكننا بدلا من ذلك نلتزم
بالمبادئ العادله للدعوه الى الوساطه
والحوار والحد من التوترات في الصراع
لتخفيف حده الوضع
في سياق اخر حذر وزير الخارجيه الصيني من
ان انتقاد الصين بشان تايوان سيكون لها
عواقب وخيمه وقال وزير الخارجيه الصيني ان
هناك خطابات تتحدث عن تغيير الوضع الراهن
من جانب واحد عبر مضيق تايوان من خلال
القوه والاكراه وتعطيل السلام والاستقرار
عبر المضيق مشيرا الى ان مثل هذه
الادعاءات تتعارض مع طبيعه العلاقات
الدوليه ولها عواقب خطيره
ذكرت وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه نقلا
عن وزيره خارجيه كوريا الشماليه قولها ان
وضع بيون يانغ كدوله تمتلك اسلحه نوويه
سيظل حقيقه لا يمكن انكارها واتهمت كوريا
الشماليه واشنطن ودول مجموعه السبع
بالتدخل في شؤونها الداخليه من خلال
المطالبه بنزع سلاحها النووي
قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد انه لن يسمح
لاي كان بالتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
لبلاده مؤكدا ان تونس ليست دوله تحت
الوصايه حسب تعبيره واضاف سعيد في كلمه
تهنئه للشعب التونسي بمناسبه عيد الفطر من
جامع الزيتونه بتونس العاصمه اضاف ان
التدخل السافر في شؤون تونس غير مقبول
مشيرا الى انه لا مجال للفتنه وان الشعب
موحد وسيبقى موحدا لتحقيق امال التونسيين
في العزه والكرامه والسياده الوطنيه حسب
تعبيره
رجحت وسائل اعلامنا امريكيه ان يشهد
الاسبوع المقبل اعلان الرئيس جو بايدن
ترشحه الانتخابات عام 20-24
ونقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست وشبكه سي ان ان
عن مصادر لم تحددها ان بايدن سيطلق حملته
الرئاسيه عبر مقطع فيديو
اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التغطيه مستمره
يسحبكم في الساعه المقبله الزميل نايف
الاحمري من الرياض اطيب التحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات